[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are going to be catching
you and one another up on our
Thanksgiving break I'm thankful I'm
thankful to be here with you Rhett
thankful to be back I'm thankful that
you are listening you who are listening
man what if you you're driving you're
you're joggin you're I sometimes I just
like to think about what people are
doing when buddy's on the elliptical
because I tend to do a lot of Cod cast
listening on the elliptical you know
when we were recently doing our little
tour and we would both go to the gym
together and you well we wouldn't go to
the gym together we would go to the gym
at the same time we would we were like
ships passing in the night you would do
your gym thing and I would do my gym
thing and I noticed you know I came up
to you and actually I came up to you and
told you that I just seen JJ Redick on
the elevator and didn't say anything to
him because I didn't realize it was him
at first then I kind of froze and then
he get off you my friend were on the
treadmill not the elliptical yeah now I
do the elliptical because it's
low-impact right so you don't to worry
about any sort of knee back all those
things yeah what's your what's your
treadmill thing my treadmill thing well
the I'm a little intimidated by the
elliptical I don't know I've never done
the elliptical the only elliptical I've
had in elliptical is we own Italy when
we yeah I remember back when we were in
like the Lillington basement you read
shows up what they just like I'm doing
it man I'm ordering an elliptical and
there's actually an episode of the
rhettandlink cast live where we a great
show where we were talking about the
fact that you had just gotten this
elliptical and I think the elliptical
was like all in on the set and I'm I
might have used it during that show and
I don't never used it after that I'm not
gonna say you yet you didn't use it
after that either but you didn't use it
after that either I use it more than you
did I was
I don't know something about it
intimidates me and there's no idea 45
minutes on the elliptical justice
moaning I just did like well I listen to
what I'm going to wreck at the end of
this buzz it this podcast okay because
it was exactly that one another podcast
uh-huh dangerous man you start to
recommend another pocket oh I feel like
you get barely listening this one you
get podcast in people's blood you want
to keep it in their blood
you have other podcasts that's my theory
I we should be secure enough and what
we're doing here that people can take it
or leave it
I am but to answer your question I don't
really have a foot I mean I don't get on
a treadmill much less an elliptical in
my in my normal workouts I don't that's
not a part of what I do at my gym I
don't do it when I'm with my trainer I'd
only do it when I'm trying to get like
extra cardio I just yeah I just I just
did it as a warm-up but there's like a
screen and you can put in there you can
put like a yeah like you're running and
you can lean on the elliptical as well
oh you can't there it's the same it's
literally the same except one is like
super low impact and you know what I'm
nervous the whole time
especially when you came up to me and
you scare me and also all of a sudden
out of nowhere you were like hey in my
ear but the other thing is with the
elliptical the things you're holding on
to with your hands or monitoring your
heart in the moment and giving you
feedback and giving you the because I
don't hold on to that railing when I'm
running I see no advantage to the
treadmill as I'm missing something
I mean you maybe look cooler did I look
cool
no okay well then there's nothing maybe
people in general do not make an
observation also nervous that I'm gonna
fall off the elliptical and faceplant so
oh yeah I said elliptical but I meant
it's ready I should be on the I'm
intimidated by the train oh well next
time I'm in a at a at a gym imma give me
only can I can I make an observation
come join you on the elliptical mean you
won't want to lip tackle sure I bet you
we could do it that'll draw attention
now did that what if I showed up at your
gym and like we literally did everything
it tough for two men ever be on
elliptical but I'm sure we can do it
okay
let me make an observation by the way
let's make a note all before we forget I
just want to make a mental note to end
on elliptical to add that
to the list you know we got we got a
ready list you know you know what I'm
talking about already thinking it
so I'm we're gonna go to your gym we're
gonna see it's not 2020 yet but uh I
have a I'm thinking that maybe in 2020
on the the podcast I'm gonna stop
wearing headphones thanks for noticing
oh it's hard to notice because your hair
is so I mean they could have been hiding
in there but I'm gonna make an
observation you are talking so much
louder than you would be if you were
just having a conversation with me
really makes me think that I must be
talking more quietly than I normally do
because I don't ever think that you're
talking loudly but like you're talking
louder then a normal person would talk
to a person this close to them and it's
because you have headphones on and it's
weird because it actually really it
really pumps into your ears actually
yeah I would have put money on that I'm
talking quiet more quietly am i talking
more quietly than I normally do Kiko
well no because I'm listening to you
through the headphones I'm hearing you I
feel like I'm talking louder in order to
keep up with you I I turned my volume
down because I was just thinking maybe
I'm gonna do no headphones because I
don't really need them I know how to
stay close to the mic I used my extra
long beard it's like whiskers and it can
makes contact with it I know how close I
am to it all right so if I'm this I'm
talking at the volume that I would
normally talk you know this is this is
link volume at the beginning of a
podcast it's a little louder than how
all you don't sound too loud in general
like someone who's listening right now
wouldn't think anything of it but I'm
just saying if we were just having a
conversation you or 24 inches from me
you wouldn't be talking to slab well I
took my headphones off and I slightly
and now you're talking normal I'm
talking quieter yes definitely
but because you were talking like this
you're a lot more I tend to use the
treadmill I am intimidated by the
elliptical keep talking and now that
this is I mean I'm just talking normally
well you're you're definitely louder in
my ears when I have the headphones on
than when I take them off mm-hm
but oh I know maybe I know you'd want to
keep those headphones on well I actually
don't know really I don't I mean as long
as Kiko has headphones on and can
monitor everything make sure that
nothing goes wrong I mean we had this
like mentality that like we're all back
in the day it was just us nobody with us
nobody was listening to us so we had to
know if something went wrong all right
fine I'll take them off but listen let's
your hair breathe
the real reason we're doing this is
something to do with your hair uh well I
actually feel more free without them on
but yeah it's like because I have so
much hair now it does create this
problem that then I have to like try to
correct and I well I think the extra
time if it's not all right I'm I'm going
raw guys we're gonna give it a shot see
I think
later in this episode when I when I talk
about what happened to me over
Thanksgiving I think I'm gonna get more
introspective I think I'm probably gonna
get a little quieter but as long as you
remain close to the mic as long as I
remain close to the microphone it'll be
fine yeah you don't want to do is go I
don't do that I'm a pro I'm a
professional sometimes I might go back
here for a fact like come back close
like that um because I'm also a
professional all right let let's just
see how this got CT cows over there
Justin knobs are you are you making me
hotter okay cuz it so you I am talking
quiet yeah now that I've taken see I
would have thought it would have been
the opposite why why do I talk louder
with the headphones on I don't know and
I don't know if I also do let me see I
guess I got to do it now well I mean you
got to you got to really put yourself in
there's chords in a neutral plate don't
overthink it just start talking so right
now I'm just talking normally like no no
you're just quieter this is no if I was
having a conversation with you okay
maybe if I'm emphasizing a point I would
be like okay I'm making a point now to
keep talking you know I'm making a point
now and now I feel like I don't know
maybe I taught the same exact level did
I feel like I'm talking the same exact
level that I was you yeah that's because
it's not a blind experiment no but I I'm
trying to respond to what I was just
hearing
that's not how science works no I'm
responding to the I'm putting myself
into the mood that I've been in for
years I know you're trying your best
with these things on it's inconclusive
that's all I'm saying well what is
conclusive is that you talk louder when
they're on well they're off I don't want
to talk louder I'll tell you something
else is conclusive you messed up your
hair yeah you didn't mess it up
it's constantly messed up no if I if I
kept it on for longer and honestly
that's not the primary reason I just sat
down and I looked into the monitor and I
was like we don't need headphones we
don't need them until we realize we do
you know what let's move on cuz I got I
got a milestone that happened to me this
morning I want to share it okay and then
at the end maybe we can come back and
say you know what this is good this
morning marks a moment in my life a
culmination of a project that I've been
investing myself in for months
now like over six months of investment
has led up to this morning oh god what
happened and I'm extremely proud of
myself I finally achieved it my daughter
drove herself and her brother to school
themselves herself that's right my
daughter Lily 16 years old has a
bonafide driver's license she got in a
car her brother
Lincoln got in the passenger seat and
they drove to school and I didn't take
him Christy didn't take him and no one
had to come back with the car because
she drove it she parked it she got out
of it and she walked into school I'm so
proud of myself it took a lot of work
okay this was not easy now I know that
you had resistance initially in this the
same resistance that I am currently
experiencing which is way to go me it's
a different it's a different time right
in LA is all
so different than where we grew up but
it has been difficult to get our kids I
cannot get LOC who will be 16 in
February I cannot get him to begin
driver's ed oh gosh
yeah and he could have I mean it I think
at 14 and a half you can start taking
the class so by 15 you're eligible to
get your learner's permit and then you
have to have it a certain amount of time
and I'm the only person in my family who
is an advocate for this for some reason
Locke doesn't care cuz he takes a goober
and Lily was not motivated but I was
very motivated I mean I got two more
kids in the house like I'm and I'm not
the one doing most of the running around
it's like Christy would be like I feel
like I'm a taxi driver like she she
wouldn't make that complaint and I would
get it cuz I mean even on the weekends
or like when I would get home girl you
got to pick up got to pick up this kid
from here and you got to take this kid
here it's bull crap and and we didn't we
did we didn't do the hop skip and a uber
thing that you did so we never got into
that because it just wasn't it wasn't
for our family okay whatever but so so
we were we were taking him around it's
like I gotta have I gotta stay on it so
it's like she but she wasn't motivated
she's got a friend who I heard her
friend say it herself she was like at
this point I'm just waiting until I turn
18 to get my license because at that
point you can just get a license and
there's no restrictions on it you don't
have to go through all the rigmarole I
just don't understand so she just wait
she's just wait Leedom automobile I know
is this freedom and I did I I had a
really hard time I was not successful at
giving Lily to transfer any excitement
or any vision for that freedom that we
experience when we turn 16 or we just
chomping at the bit like I mean in
October but when you turned 16 I was at
the DMV on all my birth oh my gosh man
and I was wait I was waiting for you to
you came to my house and pick me up and
then we just rode nowhere it was the
only was it was literally wonderfully
the only thing that I thought about for
months yeah you just and we just drove
around the idea that it's not a priority
again I know they it's it's it's a
different time
I've heard this from many parents that
there have trouble getting kids getting
their kids to care about even kids back
in North Carolina it's not just an
anything and I in and you easily just
reduce it to light well it's the screens
and I think that there there is a level
of connectivity that DIF raise the need
to get in a car and meet up with people
or show up places because you're
constantly into each other's feeds so
you're constantly in each other's faces
or you're constantly in each other's
video game thingies video game things
but even once we got in the car and we
started driving around realized we had
nowhere to go
we weren't complaining we were reveling
than just driving nowhere for hours
listening it at listening to tapes and
I'm I never really transferred that
passion to Lily I just started to into a
trend you can't just now that works I
just started instituting levels of
bribery and and control so that yeah I I
there's many ultimatums that I've made
that when you know once you're once you
have once you wouldn't be able to drive
yourself somewhere at that point you're
responsible for getting there and that
means financially to you know that's
that's where I've said okay I think this
is where you shot yourself in the foot
because among many other things like
like I said bribery like if you make it
you got to do like a 40 or 50 hour
course and then pass the test before you
can get your learner's permit which then
you got to go to the DMV it's never
simple at any point in the process but
because we never did the uber or there
was never any way for our kids to get
anywhere unless we took them and so I
started to say when Lily would say I
need to go here or I need I need to pick
up my friend or I have to show for this
thing or can you pick me up here I would
be like no but I will point out if you
had your license you could do this so
she started to feel the pain
of not being able to do some things that
she wanted to do it didn't happen a lot
but it did happen some so you didn't you
don't have that card to play because of
the uber thing he's not gonna pay he
don't have any money to pay for it okay
so you just so you might be he might he
might be able to go what one place have
you been doing that no I said when it
I'm gonna I don't know what the timeline
is right now for when it's like okay now
at this point I'm not taking you to this
place and if you want to go you have to
pay for it now okay I have to get my
wife on board with this here's the thing
I don't know how your wife thought about
this my wife is so concerned about their
safety that she's like you know I don't
know if I want him driving in LA like
what he's gonna drive he's gonna drive
yes Angeles yeah at some point I think
yeah the thing that Christy told me was
she was like well when she does get her
license she can't drive that Scion she's
got to get a car with a backup camera
and I'm like backup camera oh yeah I
backed up you know if you look at all
the times I backed up over the years I I
you could back up around the moon twice
any amount of times I backed up and I
never once had a camera that's
questionable but a camera yeah in fact
you should learn to backup without the
camera before you start using the camera
cuz I can tell you right now amber
sometimes it doesn't work sometimes just
raining and it gets blurry gets foggy
you gotta now to backup a car without
the camera in fact if you're if you give
your kid a car that's got a backup
camera you're handicapping them at the
beginning you like golf you need to put
tape over that back oh you put tape over
the backup camera until they prove that
they can backup like Steven I am Stevie
puts a post-it note over a webcam right
now I am exclusively reliant upon the
backup camera I mean I can backup it
like a granddaddy eight miles per hour
you backup Sony I come down my driveway
you know my driveways kind of steep and
you know yeah you don't give it a bit of
gas and you're going you're accelerating
like like a yeah yeah I got a rock petal
to the metal going downhill bauer's man
if there was a trashcan down there it
would obliterate it so what why was it
and why was today the first day that she
does she drove she's
her license she hasn't wanted to she's
had her license for a few months and
she's been well to park at school I saw
curb parking and they do not don't have
enough are each curb parking they do not
require parallel parking or curb parking
as part of the driving test yeah so I
had to take her out and start teaching
her to park on the curb to prepare her
give her the confidence to to park to go
to school there's no parking lot the
street parking right yeah
so I I took her out and um first of all
I never tell her I'm just like we're
going for a drive and I'm like okay I
want you to park here cycle dad I don't
know how to parallel park it's like
exactly now we're gonna do it kids man
kids it's like why do they say things
like that
dad I don't know how to parallel park
how the hell did you think we're here
and are you okay with just continuing on
in your inability yeah I was going to
understand and I don't think that we
were like that and that firm I kids
these days and that is the reason why I
was the one doing it and not Christy
because Christy you know she didn't she
doesn't want to like fuel Lily's anxiety
as she's learning but I'm like I'm kind
of fed up so I'm very firm yeah and but
she responded positively and um she
parallel parked I mean we did it you
know ten times and then I was like okay
now you can drive to school she's like I
don't feel comfortable so then before
the break every day that I could I would
ride with her to school and tell her
where to park and I would just be there
to like guide her through it but we we
like we basically found a way a place
where she could park on the curb and be
the last car so she wouldn't have to do
like the parallel parking thing so we
found that we did that for like a few
days so like yesterday I was she was
parking getting out of the car then I
was getting in and driving the car back
there was a couple of weeks of that and
did she know that today was the day
yesterday she knew that yeah and she did
and I was
mom I wasn't totally ready I was in the
shower and I was like oh man she's about
to leave for school and I don't want
Chrissie to taker I want to make sure
that she goes so I put a towel around my
waist now got out of the shower and I
run downstairs as she's yelling at
Lincoln we got to go it's time to go
which is every morning and they so then
I met him in in my front yard I'm
wearing nothing but a towel and I'm like
you can do this you can park you can go
to school on your own let's take a photo
Shh she she refused the photo I'm a
smart girl but I'm very proud of Lily
she did I mean I'm I'm I am proud of
myself but I'm proud of her too because
she did she responded you know in and
you know what she's she starting to get
it right when we got back from
Thanksgiving break we're like driving
back from the airport she's like when we
get home I'm gonna go see a friend of
mine yeah you know Mike Lee I'm like yes
you do you go girl dude it's not just
freedom I mean first of all it's
illogical because you are going to need
to drive at some point right and so the
more money you have operative the well
most people are going to need to drive
and the more experience you have under
your belt the better you will be at
things it's just like starting something
earlier like when you go back and like
ah I wish I had taken up skiing before I
was 25 years old because you take it you
start doing things that are involved
like coordination on some level the
younger you start the better you are for
the rest of your life yeah I like
learning Japanese not exactly but
similar and but then the freedom isn't
just for them it's for the parents it's
mostly about me yeah me I mean I think
I've made that abundantly I don't know
what it is I know that our wives have a
significantly higher tolerance for just
like doing things for the kids than we
do but I'm just like Jesse ain't doesn't
it just frustrate the pure hell out of
you but you have to like stop doing
something and take the kids somewhere I
mean for me I guess I'm more selfish I'm
just like no I don't
take you anywhere right now right I'm
doing exactly what I want to do and
don't and but the selfishness lines up
because don't you want to just go it's a
beautiful thing when selfishness lines
up a family but it did open I can't I
mean I got a reevaluate man but I won't
say my wife on board it did open up
another phenomenon because she went to
her friend's house that night and then
we're exhausted because of the time
change and I like texted her and I was
like when are you coming back and she
was like I don't know and I was like
well Jade's been confused because you
know I went and picked up Jade from your
house thank you for getting Jade from
the from the place for from the place so
I wouldn't have to wait until the next
day to get Jade from the place from the
kennel then on kennel kennel I really
appreciate that
that's Reena good friend getting my dog
it was pretty easy I was like Jade's
Jade's hasn't located you so she's like
anxious she's worried so you need to
come on back home she was like well I
can come out in ten minutes son come
back right now it actually worked but
then I realized I went down and I took
Jade and we were like in her bed waiting
for her to get back like just sitting on
her bed and I'm so it was the now we've
moved to the waiting up phase of kid dim
and I didn't think I'd be that guy the
waiting up for you to get home before I
go to sleep parent but I I kind of did
it for Christy because Christy was
exhausted and she was like when's Lily
coming back and I know that she would
want one of us stay up so I'd I kind of
did it for Christy I kind of did it for
me though so I don't know if this is a
new thing it doesn't sound selfish it's
weird
I was waiting up for my child to get
home yeah we I mean I do think that
there I do think we probably applied
different standards to like whether how
much you worry about Lily being out late
as a girl versus lot being out late as a
guy you know but there definitely have
been times when Jesse and I have gone to
sleep
and he's not back yet but it's part of
the plan yeah thank you does he wake you
up when he comes home he's like hey I'm
I'm back we tend to not be very plan
oriented in the McLaughlin household he
doesn't have a curfew
yeah I mean he can't stay out for into
until whenever like we know what he's
doing and where he's going and I can
locate him on it on my with my phone or
whatever but it's kind of like I know
what who you're with and what you're
doing and there's a general sort of
expectation of when you'll be back it
isn't like oh it's 1:00 a.m. I'm back
but there and it's not a normal thing
I'm just saying there have been times
when we just go to bed and it's like all
right he's we know where he's at he's
gonna he's coming home he's not like
spending the night at this house I'm not
saying it's wise I'm just saying that we
tend to not be real concerned okay I
don't know if that's if that's where I'm
headed next we haven't even gotten into
our Thanksgivings though so we should do
that we will do that in a second but
first we're going to encourage you to go
to mythical calm and pick up things that
you might like well we've got that what
are we calling the green hoodie green
wash is coming is it like a tiger
tightening it's green black it says what
on it mythical gmm yeah I mean I have
seen it but there's just a lot of things
over there you know how stuff sells out
so get on over there to mythical calm
check it out check out all the other
stuff and you know what
Rumpy boys when we do weird things to
sweatshirts you guys buy them yeah and
so they I don't know you like weird
things done to sweatshirts
so we'll keep doing it maybe until we're
tired of it until you're tired of it
we'll do it we'll keep you guessing
though at the same time mythical calm
okay let's talk about Thanksgiving we
had pretty different Thanksgivings
because you went back to North Carolina
saw family and I did not and I actually
on the complete opposite end of the
spectrum I had people at my house that
I'd never met before yeah for
Thanksgiving how did that happen and you
also you're just people walking by I
invited them in you told me you were
gonna fry woman that walks backwards up
the hill
I said come on in and tell me why you do
that it's crazy are you what you haven't
seen these people who walk backwards why
are you talking about there is a thing
that people do and I think that there's
probably a story behind it there are
more than a few people who walk
backwards up hills
some people walk backwards in general
but the people in fact there's there's a
person so she hasn't done it recently
but Kelly Oxford
you know writer filmmaker she on her
Instagram used to like show this dude
who was walking backwards everywhere and
it was just flat service walking flat I
haven't seen that but there's at least
two people in my neighborhood who walk
backwards but they're always doing it
uphill I don't know if they're like I
feel safe because if I start falling I
can okay I don't know what it is but I
saw the woman this morning walking
backwards there are two people in your
neighborhood who walk backwards up tools
and I don't know if one started nothing
was like that's a good idea but I think
this is the thing I think there's a
philosophy to it to walking backwards up
hills I can't I can't come up with what
that might be but I it was really just a
joke because I didn't invite her in that
those weren't the people that I invited
it was just people who came with friends
I think it might be a like a
physiological pain thing like an Eeyore
doesn't hurt my knee when I walk
backwards yeah I'm sure we can figure it
out are they older people now uh over 40
well just me I guess I'm old well and
you you told me that you were frying two
turkeys and I was a little worried about
that three yeah triple Turkey the triple
Turkey triple Turkey so that you must
have invited a lot of strangers to your
house well it's a little complicated I
assume that it's just people Jesse knew
that you didn't know no no no that there
were two people who neither of us had
ever met isn't this what you said last
year you didn't want to do this year you
probably did I say a lot of things you
were talking about last year kids day
out whenever they wanted a bunch of
people were like you know
I don't I think I'll do it differently
well I was okay here's here's what
here's what I'll say you weren't at that
Thanksgiving last year no I was at home
so you've heard a you've heard I feel
like I was playing cards at a gas
station
I feel like I can speak more freely
about last year's Thanksgiving now that
were a year out from it but so one of my
friends invited a lot of people to
Thanksgiving celebration of
friendsgiving if you will but it wasn't
really a friendsgiving because it was
the majority of the people who were
there I feel like I didn't know or at
least half I can't really remember but a
lot of people I didn't know and I didn't
really mind it but the thing that really
was a problem is that they had gotten
this guy who was a chef to make all the
food and it was like the expectations
were really really high but then he just
did a really la sort of approach I
remember that he did a dressing that is
best described as a deconstructed
dressing you know like he was just kind
of like pieces of bread that I mean it
was it this is all recap I know but I
feel like it's a setup for why I did
things the way I did a mission okay and
I did not tell I'm keeping this is all
new information cuz I didn't say I
didn't talk crap about the food I'm
doing that a year later oh there were
some vegan friends of mine who brought a
bunch of vegan desserts like there
wasn't even a freaking pumpkin pie that
wasn't there was no butter in any of the
desserts
it was just like listen get y'all if you
think Thanksgiving if you--if just a
couple of times a year you're gonna let
it all hang out let it all hang out
unzip it unbutton it you know and
listening unfurl okay I get it if you're
a vegan you're not going to put butter
in something but if if you're not a
vegan put butter in it and put a lot of
butter and a lot of sugar and get it to
taste good like let that be the goal so
you were focused on a traditional date
sugar and butter first there were so
many you so much butter and so much
sugar in fried turkey and a lot of meat
so yeah I deep-fried three turkeys and
the reason I did three Turkey
is because when our friend
Ginny found out that I was deep-frying
turkeys
she said you mind if I bring by just a
turkey breast and you can fry that too
for my leftovers I love her it I was
like of course I don't know okay so
you're counting her turkey breasts
yeah you got the VAT it's hot you might
as well dunk another right it was like
and I was almost like you know what I'll
start with your turkey breast because
that'll be it's a little bit of a guinea
pig it wasn't a guinea pig it was a
turkey but it would be like my test
Turkey and and she was funny cuz she was
like my dad has this tradition of like
completely cooking a separate turkey
breast and that is your leftover so you
don't there's not a lot of pressure on
the main turkey to be left over and you
didn't you've got this completely like
prime turkey breast that is ready to go
and she was like and can you put this
poultry magic rub on it she gave she
gave me the rope she brought me the
turkey breast and the rub I was like
sure no problem
but with the other two and she and she
got it was like a Butterball turkey it
was like you know a turkey that was like
nice and packaged turkey breast nice and
packaged it comes with it it's already
got like a sodium and sugar sort of
solution in it so you don't need to
brine it but of course my wife gets the
like Heritage Farm organic never frozen
turkey that's been like you know this
massage massage his turkeys probably
like taking calculus classes to get
ready for this moment and these turkeys
were like eighty-five dollars a piece
for a 13 pound turkey just to put things
into perspective these were some
expensive ass turkeys it wasn't a bigger
turkey because there when the
well-treated turkeys are smaller right
they don't have those giant antibiotic
boobies breasts you know they're just
like pulsating and ready to be eaten
No
these are like a little more natural
these turkeys have you know they've
they've run around the yard a little bit
yeah so uh I gotta get this right these
are some expensive turkeys and I did two
turkeys because I did the whole like you
roughly do a pound per person and that's
what you're gonna get leftovers with
that and I was like you know I want a
lot of leftovers and I want him if one
turkey turns out better than the other
you know give me two turkeys so but I
did the brining I brined it two days
ahead of time I did the the rub and I
did all all this homemade now I followed
the Pioneer Woman's recipe me and the
Pioneer Woman are like this woman you
know television yeah
and so I followed her brining recipe and
her rubbing recipe and and then I
injected I had my way with this these
turkeys I rubbed him I injected him I'm
random and we didn't understand why you
invited strangers over and I made too
much time with those turkeys you can
you're more like you can get away with
more bragging well when the Pete you
know people don't know you that well
they'll sit and listen to you brag about
what you did to your turkeys for you
know our I know I actually had a lot of
self-deprecating talk about the turkeys
because I was nervous about him because
what is the one thing that everyone's
worried about with turkey and what is
the one thing that people like you ham
men think complain about you don't want
to dry turkeys to dry and my theory is
that it isn't that people don't like
turkey is that people don't like dry
turkey and that most people and a lot of
people who do not like Turkey have been
deprived of adequately moist turkey and
therefore they've come to wrong
conclusions about turkeys it isn't
actually dry if you do it right so as I
was but I didn't you know I'm
deep-frying these things I hadn't done
that in like 15 years one time Chris and
I did it back in North Carolina but it
was different I got the electric fryer
so I didn't do the whole gas situation
I read the statistic that 40 300 people
a year burn their homes down front
deep-fried turkeys which sounds like a
made-up stat but I saw it on many
websites so it must be true so this is
basically like a giant deep fryer that
has a lid in everything got the oil
peanut oil
put it in there it's all about getting
the right level on that oil well there's
they make it easy there's a there's a
men line and a max line and if you
basically said if your turkey is a
certain size or certain pounds if you
put it at the max line it'll be covered
or whatever so I did that it was fine
finished that first Turkey it looked
great did the second one in the third
one it was not easy to hold to get the
temperature because you wanted anyway I
was a little bit worried because I
thought I went a little too long but boy
the turkey talk started as soon as
people started biting into those breasts
and of course I had I I did dark meat
and white meat on the platter that dark
meat on one side and why me and I did
the whole thing I me and me and Nick we
sat there and we just trimmed it we took
all the meat off that it was completely
just if an electric got her like Jenny
the way that she paid for her turkey is
she let me use her electric knife and so
I cut it up it had a little bit of that
it was the brine flavor was coming
through because I put some orange peel
in there only because the Pioneer Woman
wanted me to and I do it ever she says
and yang a lone wolf yeah and all I can
say is the turkey was a success and I'm
very proud of myself
I mean it was the moistness breast this
side of the Mississippi I'm sure east of
the Mississippi there was some very
moist breasts because of people in the
south can really cook now the Pioneer
Woman is west of the Mississippi as well
she probably could because she's on the
plains but no and so and Jesse was like
well you're in trouble now because
you've got to do that again you you have
to do this every year that were here
because you've shown that you can't like
living like above the ground but the
problem is so much time in fact I
actually had this whole idea that I was
going to Instagram this process I had a
whole character Terry and his turkey
tutorials I had a whole character a pair
of glasses a whole thing that I was
going to do and as soon as I got into
looking at the directions I was like oh
gosh I don't have the ability to be
entertaining and do this
right maybe next year Terry and his
turkey tutorial sorry gonna come back be
back we'll be here for the first time
because now I understand what I'm up
against Turkey Terry had to tarry until
2020 but it was a success but the the
the phenomenon of and just so you you
know I'm gonna talk about my
Thanksgiving and then I'm gonna hand it
over to link and he's gonna talk all
about his Thanksgiving it's I'm not
intentionally hogging the conversation
every way that we have a plan
don't bring a hog into this but what
Turk you did have a hog on your
Thanksgiving I assume so but you but you
didn't have them man I should have kept
some of that breast behind for you so
you could see how moist it is but anyway
having people I'm a hand man I wasn't
particularly I like to save the ham for
Christmas that's the thing I I'm a hand
Christmas ham and I like it so they're
so close together the holidays are so
close together they're like a month
apart so I feel like ham ham got a hand
man have too much ham I feel like I
can't I wasn't super excited about
having people that I didn't know because
I tend to be a hermit and a loner and
I'm the kind of guy that when there's a
bunch of people in my house I like go
upstairs for a little bit I'm that guy
but my wife is my wife is you know and
she's like the most welcoming and
hospitable person on the face of the
planet and will talk to a stranger until
like 4:00 a.m. and so I was like no this
is good I mean I want to adjust anyway
to having people that I don't know it's
great how do people you don't know show
up is it the new people that I do know
so okay so it's like hey bring friends
bring other people well it's like hey
we're in LA but you invite one you
invite this one family and they're like
well we're gonna we were gonna get
together with so-and-so can we bring
them uncle and she was gonna bring
so-and-so and he might bring so-and-so
it's you know it's the change in effect
yeah and I was and we were like sure yes
I must been like 18 people whatever and
but it was great and the thing that it
was nice getting to know new people but
it also created this dynamic
where we had not planned on like what
are we doing like we we knew what what
time we were gonna eat approximately of
course we ate later than that and then
it was like we kind of late like we were
eating it like 6 o'clock so alright what
what about Thanksgiving night
like what how long are people gonna stay
well people with kids kind of started
peeling off peeling off peeling out and
then a few people stayed and we're like
let's watch a movie and I don't know who
suggested it somehow we decided that we
were going to watch Footloose Footloose
Kevin Bacon 1984 okay I guess have you
seen that I'm an American yes I have not
seen that sounds sounds painful
it's like your boots loose like there's
a medical drama yeah I have seen my
foots loose what but I have not seen
flippy with the ankle I don't know I
haven't seen Footloose since you know
that wave in the 80s where most people
were watching Footloose so I kind of
knew you know I've seen you I've seen it
and you know that I know about like the
famous speech and to the City Council
and stuff like that that you see like on
YouTube and that kind of thing and of
course the dances I know about the
dances and socks that's really at the
beginning but in fact most of that like
close foot action already that tom is
Tom Cruise in that know your think about
risky business probably oh he's dancing
was it just a shirt do you know that
John Lithgow is in he plays the pastor
because the story of Footloose is that
it's this sort of super conservative
Midwestern town which I actually thought
was really interesting in light of Bleak
Creek and like this story that we didn't
think about Footloose one time when we
were writing but it's interesting no I
didn't because you've got this super
conservative town where the pastor has a
lot of control he won't let him dance
and you can't dance and Kevin Bacon
comes in new kid from out of town and
horse dancing is his thing and it's the
story of him trying to get the town to
dance I mean that's a Thanksgiving movie
now it isn't a thanksgiving movie right
but I discovered something that I've
never heard anybody point out I almost
tweeted it
but then that takes a little more effort
turkey Terry didn't feel like tweeting
yeah at the end of the movie spoiler
alert there's a dance the town gets to
dance at the dance the camera is moving
across the spread of food that's at the
dance and the food at the dance is
unlike any food at any dance there has
ever been because it's like whole baked
pies and cakes Thanksgiving and then as
you as the camera tilts up and you see
in the background at the end of the
table a turkey
there is a turkey on the table
it's Thanksgiving it's a Thanksgiving
movie but it's not Thanksgiving it's
just their dance and I was like has
anybody ever noticed this before there's
a turkey and then I thought about
pausing it and rewinding it to make sure
that it was a turkey but then I was like
what if I rewind and it's not a turkey
that'll ruin it for me and I'm plus
they're strangers watching tributaries
this guy pause in the movie at the end
and rewinding it it was funny though
because there's one of those things it's
one of those things that happens that
feels like a glitch in the matrix
because turkey Terry has spent all this
time on the turkeys getting the turkeys
just right do you see it turkeys
everywhere and then all of a sudden he's
watching Footloose and there's a turkey
on the table what are the chances this
is a glitch in the matrix hundred
percent and I want that glitch to remain
and I do think that it's true that there
is a turkey on the table I mean there's
pies on the table and then there's a
large brown baked bird at the end of the
table so Footloose is a thanksgiving
movie and you know what shepard watched
it with me
watch it with us cuz jesse and i and
whoever else was left he was into it you
know we we learned things kevin bay
King Kevin Bacon is really held up you
know you the thing that you do now when
you watch movies and you're looking at
an actor in your lights 1984 how old was
he then how old is he now and then you
start looking at modern pictures of
people think you start seeing how the
actors in the movie have aged and you
find out oh Crispin Sean Penn's brother
who plays his friend he's dead he died
in 2006 oh that's sad and then you're
like what does Kevin making look like
you're like whoa Kevin Bacon looks good
what does Kevin Bacon been doing to look
so good not eating bacon I'll tell you
that dancing dancing so and then that
you want to hear about my face I don't
yeah the only the last thing I'll say is
that watching a movie on Thanksgiving
night opened up the floodgates and ended
up seeing more movies in a shorter
period of time we went to the theater
twice saw knives out highly recommended
and then I've told her he told you about
this Saul Ford vs. Ferrari which is the
ratio of how much I wanted to see a
movie to how good it was like I didn't
want to see that movie at all it's like
a racing movie I don't care
Ford versus Ferrari you got to see it
it's a group it's a great movie don't
make that face have you seen it you need
to see it because I mean of course it's
got great actors in it but it's just a
really compelling story my kids loved it
I loved Jojo rabbit is the best movie of
the year so you talk about that but I
saw that before Thanksgiving what about
your Thanksgiving meal I didn't have it
I didn't have a turkey I mean I'm trying
not to you know what I'm gonna try to
make this introspective and not a downer
but I think that there's a I did spoiler
has some downer elements to to my
Thanksgiving so it's like it doesn't
have it's not bright-eyed and
bushy-tailed like you're you're like
you're like you're Footloose turkey teri
shenanigans
so those fillers and fancy-free we
didn't have you know when we went to my
nanny's house it's like you know she she
and aunt Vicki there we didn't want to
burden them with having to make food and
you know some nanny was if she's not
able to make her signature dressing that
we used that dressing that we would get
to like slather that gravy
every year I grew up eating then it was
like the perfect Thanksgiving dressing
it's like she written a recipe down uh
because that's how you got it you got a
hold on those recipes that's a good
point recipes from your relatives really
need to ask really really important that
they write those down that's one of the
ways that we remember Jessie's
grandmother is yeah I need to do that
cakes that she used to make yeah that's
a good point because she's not able to
make that and like we didn't want to
burden him to have to make stuff so like
we brought in Bojangles and so like how
our Thanksgiving ain't like good you
know my kids were just so excited I yeah
they couldn't because they knew were you
planning this like we're gonna get
Bojangles for Thanksgiving at nanny's
house and so that's quite a silver
lining I mean it's not a Thanksgiving
meal but it but it's Bojangles and we
never get that so it was pretty great
but you know they're they're not doing
well so it's like and we're talking to
nanny about like she's like I want to I
got to pull my will together you know I
got a that's fun table talk and she's at
so here we are on Thanksgiving we're
like trying to we're talk about the
finer points of the will you know which
is a very important thing to talk about
and it's what we have been talking about
it leading up to Thanksgiving but like
it was since we were together in the
same room we were talking out a little
bit so it it tends to be a bit of a
downer talking about a will but it's
also very important and it's like let's
your lawyer yeah so like that was kind
of the vibe this year there wasn't there
was no go into a gas station in playing
cards like we we planned things out a
little better but also mom and Luis
weren't able to show up because of
Louis's health and actually the last
time I talked about it on your biscuits
you know the I guess it was the whole
episode devoted to their visit out here
and how he he basically almost died
right and then he he recovered well
enough that he was able to they were
able to fly back home and then I
remember telling the story that like
when he got home he was like blowing off
the his his garage with the leaf blower
good good good well I haven't talked
about it since then but the update there
is a few days after that he had a series
of strokes you know about this but but
but they don't so I'll just kind of
bring him up to speed and again that was
back in April so ever since April he's
been in and out of the of the hospital
and Rehab facilities in order to to
regain the ability to walk and gain gain
gain the strength to do things and he's
it's been it's been very difficult but
right before we came back home for
Thanksgiving was the first time that he
came back home since April he's been in
and out of facilities this first time
you were home yeah like I mean back in
July when we went home for when we were
filming in Buies Creek for you know the
Bleak Creek conversation is documentary
that is now on committeth good morning
we would film during the day and then
every night I would go visit mom and
Lois in the hospital and he was he was
basically he was on a ventilator mm well
ventilator may not be the right word he
had a he had a feeding tube and he was
he was not conscious it was bad like he
had like four or five near-death
experiences once leaving LA since April
and so this is the first time seeing him
in person and he he finally has gotten
back home which is great news so he is
on a road to recovery but they weren't
able to come to nanny's house we we had
Thanksgiving Bojangles at nanny's and
then the later that afternoon we went to
Mom's and saw Louis and like he lost 65
pounds he's like looks like a totally
different person yeah you know it's like
I mean he looked a whole lot better than
he did when I saw him you know all
swollen and ha
little every night when I visit them in
July but so in a way it was it was
difficult but it was also very good to
to see him at home and know that like he
had just been there a few days and like
they were very thrilled to be there I
mean you go through but we've learned so
much through the process we're like just
talking to my mom
multiple times a week and just seeing
how slowly things move when you're
trying to recover like that but for him
to be back at home was a big milestone
so it was it was certainly the the one
of the biggest headlines for us all to
be grateful for us seeing him there and
then for his side of the family he's got
all his siblings that he wanted to visit
and then so there was a question whether
he'd be able to leave the house and have
enough strength to I just like well
visit he can he can walk some but he
just you know his his body kind of
wasted away as he was dealing with a
series of infections that led to the
near-death experiences that I was
talking about so yes just physically
gaining the strength to be able to walk
but he can he can stand he can like get
in a wheelchair they're doing like
therapy at home where he's like
continuing to regain strength but he was
able to go visit and be with his family
when they got together on the next day
so it's like it was it was so it was it
was difficult going home and then like
you go to Nana's house and we had a big
Thanksgiving spread there it was
absolutely amazing so and I remember
talking about our highlights of the year
last year that like mom and Luis came to
that they came to you to my Nana's house
my my dad's mom's I talked dad's mom I
talked about that but of course they
weren't able to come to that but and and
you know there's a sense of when you
only go back home even at Nana's where
it was like there was a lot more
positivity it's still like okay they're
still you know it's the second
Thanksgiving without my uncle and
without Papa Nana's
you know lifelong partner and so there's
a sense of loneliness and loss that
still is very much there and I think
it's it was important for us to be there
and to to talk about that some was part
of it so it's like you find yourself
talking about those things as well and
like my aunt saying she felt like that
this Thanksgiving was worse than the
previous one because when Thanksgiving
rolled around last year she was still in
shock of the loss of you know her
husband so in a lot of ways it was like
oh this is the new normal for us but you
know it's you cheat it's you try to see
it not as I'm trying to see it not as
much just as like a down or oh isn't
this sad but more like it's sobering and
it it does provide an occasion for us to
say what we can still be thankful for
but it's not easy to do that but I do
think we tried to we try to make the
best of it like we dug out those
remember those old cornhole boards when
we did that we did that commercial for
ajj cornhole not the cornhole song but
we also did a commercial for them we
show that in your grandma's in their
yard this time you play cornhole
[Music]
cornhole gives me confidence well I was
like going through their shed out there
and I found the cornhole set and like in
the corn bags and they weren't all moldy
and like we sat out there who says ajj
cornhole in the corner not that not that
was on ours but apparently we got a
bunch of free sets and like we left one
at Nana's house so like we're out there
playing cornhole and having a good time
but there's you know it's it's it's also
difficult when you you just go back as a
family once a year maybe twice but the
last time we had been back as a family
was last Thanksgiving so it's you go
back it's been a whole year everybody's
a year older and the older you are the
more palpable the age piling on is you
know so it's like
so it's it's sobering in that way you
know I got more gray every year but you
you know and so then I I just found
myself starting to think more about and
it's as our as my relatives get older
it's like you start to think about like
what's what does care look like what is
what does care for my mom looked like as
she has no siblings and I have no
siblings and I live out here in Los
Angeles you know it's like if it was if
it was her going through that and and
not Louis as much as I tried to be there
for her long distance over the phone and
provide support like how would that be
different if it was if it was mom that
had was having the strokes and you know
it's like you you can't you know I guess
there's a lot to plan for it's like you
can't over plan for things that you
don't know exactly you just got to be
ready for the unexpected and and take it
as it comes right but I just couldn't
help but start to think about as
relatives as loved ones get older I
think well how do you how do you start
to interact well you know and there's a
lot of like there's a lot of
technicalities like what you're talking
about
you know with your nanny who's what
she's in her 80s right yeah and like
she's she's getting her will stuff
together now which is this is what a lot
of people do right because there's
there's not just the will what she had
one but then you got to update it to so
it's not that she didn't have one but it
needed to be drastically updated because
it had been so long and and then there's
like the end-of-life care questions you
know and like what who's gonna take
who's gonna take care like right at this
point everybody's still kind of you know
no one's buying by themselves because
like your nanny has her sister and then
Louis has your mom right and like my
parents have each other so it's like but
what what about when they don't yeah and
don't have that for all of that to
happen - Louis it's like that was so out
of the unexpected at his age
you know it's like especially when you
have grandparents that are living you
know it's an every year for years we go
back and say well you kind of think in
the back of your mind it's like is this
the last is this the last year that you
see the oldest relatives but then
there's think the things that last year
that blindsided us and then this year
that blindsided us with what happened to
Louis so it's you know it's again I get
and yeah I don't have any firm
conclusions I'm I'm trying to find the
you know the there's still a lot to be
thankful for and I think we are and I'm
certainly glad that we went home but
it's it isn't I don't know it's a
reminder that as much as you can't plan
for it there's some things you can't
like having your will in place and
talking about it so that people know
what your wishes are and I think it's
it's good for all of us I know that we
had to pull our wills together years ago
if the younger you are the more fun it
is to pour your will together because it
makes you feel good that you're getting
it out of the way but the older you get
it starts to it starts to feel a little
bit more bleak you know and people just
don't I mean a lot of people just put
that stuff off you know they don't they
don't want to have those conversations I
mean just like you know just a
conversation that you have to have with
your as you get to be middle aged the
conversation you have to have with your
parents about you know in like it would
be a conversation that I have with my my
parents and also my brother right you
can figure out that okay what are we
gonna you know when it gets to a place
where our parents can't take care of
themselves what does that look like yeah
one of them gonna be living with you
with me are they gonna be you know we're
gonna find some kind of care for them
like there's a really difficult
conversations to have but you kind of
what you don't want to do is you don't
want to be having to have those
conversations in the midst of the crisis
right I sound like an insurance
salesman but but that but that I mean
it's true you know you got to have those
difficult conversations right but it's I
mean and then we were staying with
Christie's sister and we had a great
time there and then you know it's it's
nice because my nephew Nia my he's like
he's a little nut running around so it's
it's it's nice to have the kids in the
mix you know like he and Lando having a
great time and but yeah it was a bit of
a I don't know it's it also not being
there so then when you go back it's like
oh wow everybody's everybody's older you
know ain't nobody getting younger so
it's it just feels it feels like man I'm
you can't you're not an active part of
your of your loved ones lives or you're
a much less active part of it just
because of the the sheer distance
associated yeah so it's and it's just
the way it is and I think at this point
it's it's it's the life that we live you
know and it's it's not unusual it's not
wrong well it's not but you know what it
is is it's very unusual in the course of
human history because it isn't until
very recently like a blink of an eye in
the in the timescale of human history
where people like what do you mean you
don't live at the same place with your
parents yeah like everyone did that and
it still and obviously that's still the
case in a lot of cultures but especially
here it's just like it's the exception
to the rule if you live you know a lot
of people are still kind of close in
proximity but a lot of people were
actually in the same homes you know with
multiple multi multi-generational homes
and yeah I don't know we haven't really
figured out what like the expectation
that
I think the expectation still holds that
your your your family is gonna be
responsible for for your care in one
sense but it doesn't that doesn't mean
what it meant for for most of the
history which is like directly
responsible for your care it's more like
no no we're gonna get someone who's who
whose job it is to care for old people
I mean that's what there's a huge
industry right and it's just like it's
just a way it's a weird thing because it
wasn't ever like that it wasn't like oh
there are people whose job it is to come
to our village and take care of the old
people know that we do that yeah and I
don't you know I haven't again I'm still
starting I've been prompted because of
this experience to think about it but
it's not like I'm starting to figure it
out or or but I do know that I'm not
like well I wouldn't that sounds gross
or I would never do that or like passing
pre-emptive judgment on what other
people do or like you know it's yeah I
know it's gonna be complicated but
thinking about it a little bit at a time
is better than just continuing to put it
off so I think that's that's one of the
applications and I think another one is
just being I I'm very grateful that we
went back and the time that we spent
there was was quality you know it was it
was special at each place I remember you
know it's is the I choose to hang on to
the moments and the memories like when I
I do is off after eating all the
Bojangles on on the couch bed that nanny
sleeps on in the living room and I woke
up to Lando in my aunt just dying
laughing because Lando was showing her
how to use the the face filter thingies
on I don't know if a snapchat or
Instagram I don't even use that stuff
but like she was cackling and this was
her first experience with it first
experience with it says like you you
know
you eat your food you doze off and then
you wake up to that and it's like that's
that's that's what we're here for
you here for those moments win here for
those filters you here for those moments
when everybody can everybody can share a
laugh and everybody can share yeah what
we know we're sharing the hurt of
whatever it is that we're all feeling
but then at the same time we can also
laugh at how stupid we look with these
with these face filters on did was their
turkey served at Nana's house yeah so
some people did consume turkey but my
dad brought a honey-baked a pork he had
smoked a pork a bunch of pork loins the
week before for something else and he
had a few more and so he heated one of
those up and that's what I eaten it was
amazing mmm ham man we've got a lot of
you think for ya I'm thankful for what
everything that we've had and the things
that we don't have anymore I'm thankful
that I once had it and that there was
still a lot that we did have and to be
had so and carry that spirit of
thankfulness through the seasons
don't just be thankful one day out of
the year be thankful every day be
thankful that another day has happened
and what you're a part of it yeah and
speaking of that I mean we're gearing up
for our top our top tens of the year
that's the next episode the last episode
of the year the next episode we're gonna
do yeah top ten best moments of each of
us oh yeah in 2019 personal professional
otherwise what what else is there you
gonna shut them down with a wreck I got
a wreck it's a podcast you might be
familiar with Radiolab which is one of
my favorite podcast already well Chad
Appa Murad one of the probably saying
his name wrong is one of the hosts of
that show was going to do an episode or
so about Dolly Parton
and then when he got into the process he
realized that there was a whole podcast
so now there's a podcast called Dolly
Parton's america which i think is it's
still a limited series seven or eight
episodes in right now but I've been
listening to it I love it and it's not
just it's because it's not just about
the details of like the history of died
Parton and like her career but it's how
an icon like her has built this audience
and then like what what she has done
what that says about our country in the
state that we're in right now and the
polarization of America and like the
political divide and how dolly has sort
of overcome that and in certain ways and
why that might be and I don't even know
where they're going with it but it's
just a really insightful like personal
podcast and I've always been a fan of
Dolly Parton I mean I've been to
Dollywood
I made the pilgrimage but she's a
special lady all right that's Dolly
Parton Dolly Parton's America slightly
recommend hashtag your biscuits let us
know what you think about the
conversations we had today and I gotta
get out of here because I have to not
pick up my daughter from high school
high school keep being grateful give me
any thankful speak at your necks never
stop to watch more ear biscuits click on
the playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best